When I arrived, I was immediately struck by the color.
It was pouring rain that day and it was very windy.
Just these beautiful images of people...
...with brightly colored umbrellas...
...and the wind blowing the umbrellas away,...
...and that struck me immediately as a painter.
The color here is so different.
My name is Kelly Beeman.
I'm an artist from New York.
I've always had a certain curiosity about St. Petersburg,...
...and I'm not really sure why...
...because I didn't know very much about the city before coming here,...
...but in my imagination,...
...it always had this sort of mystique.
It's a densely populated city with a lot of ornate decoration,...
...a lot of sort of sophisticated-looking people.
You have this dichotomy here.
There's the Imperial and the Romantic and the Baroque and Neoclassical,...
...and then there is the Stalinist and the Communist.
I want to depict specific objects and places.
My paintings of people almost making eye contact,...
...and that's very, very important to me.